on this saturday night
where the virus thrives restaurant
owners
argue they're not the cause but health
experts disagree
restaurants unfortunately are super
spreading environments
the two men fighting for the white house
it's going to be
a very interesting three days
three days we can put an end to this
presidency
the final push in a campaign too close
to call
a polarized portland prepares for chaos
the protests are going to continue
because of
the political landscape the staging
ground of a divided america
plus remembering the man who played the
original suave
secret agent
[Music]
global national with robin gill
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin with breaking news out of
alberta
an investigation is underway after a
canadian soldier was shot and killed
at cfb wainwright in a release canada's
department of national defense says the
soldier was participating
in a live fire training exercise when
the incident occurred
the third battalion of princess
patricia's canadian light infantry was
taking part in the exercise
the soldier was airlifted to a hospital
in edmonton
but died this morning global news has
learned the soldier
killed was a reservist with the royal
westminster regiment
based out of bc the prime minister
tweeted
our hearts go out to their loved ones
and canadian forces colleagues
know that we are mourning with you and
are here to support you
during this difficult time now to the
pandemic
canada's deputy prime minister has been
tested for kova 19 and is now waiting
for results
in self-isolation christia freeland says
the test was prompted by an alert from
the covet app
and tonight there is more evidence that
the virus is surging
across this country quebec and ontario
both recorded more than a thousand new
cases today
manitoba was over 300 winnipeg will face
more restrictions come monday
restaurants won't be allowed to have
dine in service and that's something
quebec and ontario have already done
but restaurant owners say they're being
unfairly targeted
arguing new data shows their
establishments
aren't the source of the spread michael
couture reports
these are likely the last few meals
inside winnipeg restaurants for a while
after a spike in covet 19 cases the
province moved the city
into the red zone meaning starting
monday restaurants will have to close
dining rooms i can see a decent amount
of restaurants not participating or not
opening up after this and i can see that
a lot of restaurants laying off a lot of
staff and a lot of people are going to
be unemployed
one province over in ontario patrons are
hanging on to the last few days of patio
weather
while trying to support local
restaurants ottawa mayor jim watson is
working with local health officials
on a list of recommendations for the
province to allow
indoor dining to return to the capitol i
do have faith that we will
reopen next week sarah chon has been
lucky she was able to extend her patio
and she believes restaurants
will take proper precautions when
they're allowed indoor dining again
you're going to see people wanting to be
very safe because the last thing we're
going to want is to go
back again in a week or in two weeks or
in a month from now and shut it down
inside again and lay your employees off
again and waste all your food again
you're going to see people you know
being really cautious the bar and
restaurant owners point to numbers
released this week as justification for
why they should be allowed to ease
restrictions
it showed they were not the biggest
source of covid19 outbreaks in ontario
however epidemiologists caution those
numbers
aren't that reliable it's data of about
13 weeks
and for at least four of those 13 weeks
the restaurants and bars and gyms have
been closed
so can you conclude anything about their
role in transmission
probably not the gyms have similar
issues that weren't fully captured in
the latest modeling numbers according to
the country's top
doctor in an interview on the west block
with mercedes stevenson
globally the literature has shown that
super spreading events
occur in those those environments so
and but but i think it needs
re-evaluation on an
ongoing basis restaurant owners just
hope that reevaluation happens
before they're forced to shut down for
good
michael couture global news ottawa
new federal projections suggest
canadians need to cut their contacts by
25 percent to prevent covid19 outbreaks
mercedes stephenson spoke with canada's
top doctor for this week's edition of
the westlock mercedes why is dr teresa
tam so concerned about the next phase of
the pandemic
robin dr tam is very concerned about the
coming weeks and the potential for
a third wave partially because only a
slim minority of canadians are actually
immune to the covid19 virus
at the last measurement we're only a you
know a few percentage points
in terms of our the immunity in our
population
that leaves over 90 percent of the
population or 95 percent of the
population still vulnerable
so that tells us that
resurgences can happen if we
let our guard down i also asked dr tam
about what we learned from the first
phase of the pandemic
and what canada should have done
differently
i think one of the questions often posed
is
should we have closer borders earlier i
think looking back we will see that
it introduces difficult to prevent
introduction of an invisible virus
and if your thinking is in one country
is probably in
in many so that that's a different way
of looking at it
decisive action and fast action is
important
dr tam says in hindsight warning
canadians about the possibility of
community spread
could have helped you know maybe better
risk
communication making sure people know
that while
transmission really wasn't happening
very much in canada at the time it could
happen that could occur i also spoke
with dr
tam about why she felt the situation was
worse in canadian long-term
care homes for seniors than in other
countries tune in for the full interview
on tomorrow's the west walk
robin mercedes stephenson in ottawa
thanks mercedes
england is going back into lockdown in
the hopes of slowing the spread of
covert 19.
and so now is the time to take action
because
there is no alternative the month-long
lockdown will start on thursday
all pubs and retail shops will have to
close essential businesses like grocery
stores
will stay open so will schools
universities and construction
sites the uk reached a grim pandemic
milestone today
surpassing one million confirmed coven
19 cases
the race for the white house is in its
final stretch it will be the first
election in u.s history
with the majority of ballots cast before
election day
but as president donald trump and his
democratic rival joe biden
make their final pitches to voters there
are concerns that
millions of mail-in votes won't be
counted on time
jennifer johnson reports
campaigning across two swing states u.s
president donald trump
and democratic presidential candidate
joe biden are in a race to the finish
this could only happen to me and how are
you doing we're tied we're tithed
how the hell how can i be tied there's
nothing
that he can do to stop the people of
this nation from voting in overwhelming
numbers and taking back this democracy
biden campaigning with former president
barack obama is hammering president
trump on the covet 19 pandemic
as new cases break almost daily records
costing about 230 000 americans their
lives
but the president doesn't believe the
pandemic will cost him the election
counting on republican dominated states
and more minority votes
you have a big red wave that has formed
as you probably noticed
we're doing very very well with the
african-american vote we're doing very
very well with the hispanic vote
there are renewed concerns that millions
of mail-in ballots won't be counted on
time
due to delays and many democrats allege
fraud within the u.s postal service
will these be republican ballots or will
they be democratic ballots
we just don't know the answer to that
question it's possible that these
judicial decisions
may hurt republicans as much as
democrats close to 90 million americans
have already cast their ballots in early
voting
a record even professional sports teams
are opening up their stadiums and arenas
to let the masses in it's been so long
since you know we've been able to go to
any
games or anything so it's kind of nice
being in there you know reminding me of
good times boats already cast in texas
have soared past 9 million
more than voted in the 2016 election
never before have more americans wanted
their voices to be heard
the earlier the better in an election
still three days away
jennifer johnson global news washington
many americans are eager to have their
voices heard right now because
the country is so divided the gap
between republicans and democrats has
never been
so clear and that's raising concerns
about what could happen
after the election as sarah mcdonald
explains tensions in some cities
including portland oregon are already at
a boiling point
you don't have to look far not going to
allow the cancer from portland to spread
out everywhere else
to find the deepening political divide
running through washington state
tensions hit a boiling point friday at
dueling demonstrations
trump finally stands up and says america
is a great country
but not everybody sees it that way
especially in portland oregon
this deeply democratic city caught in
the crosshairs of political posturing
and unrest
at the height of the racial justice
movement what is going on which saw
federal agents
and tear gas targeting protesters and
activists
like ty carpenter tensions are rising so
i think what the election just stays
away
who knows what's going to happen
portland may be one of the most
progressive cities in the country
but take a short drive in any direction
and you're likely to find yourself
in trump territory that's where
democrats like david levin
find themselves outnumbered suburban
parts of the state that swing red
further polarized in the current
political climate the other side will
simply just
argue yell scream call names and i can't
even get more than two sentences in
some republicans we spoke to even in
strongholds feel
intimidated too i do i'm always
shy about saying who i'm going to vote
for because of that
and especially with coworkers
with police presence now heightened
statewide at ballot drop boxes and a bid
to curb any potential for voting related
violence
we're kind of scared either way as to
what's going to happen
some americans on both sides of the fray
are second guessing
if the land of the freight will remain
home to them
i have no hope with trump as he's
elected
and i mean jokingly we've talked about
maybe we need to move to canada
and it's now eerily quiet in portland in
the same streets once dominated by those
demonstrations
for weeks police and the city once again
bracing for political unrest be it
anarchists militant extremists
or everyday people with just days to go
until the presidential election
robin sarah mcdonald in portland oregon
the world is also watching to see who
wins the white house
a lot is at play here globally world
order foreign policy and economic ties
over the last four years donald trump
has at times
alienated allies and withdrawn the u.s
from several international agreements
here's krystal gumansing as long as i'm
president of the united states
iran will never be allowed to have
a nuclear weapon the taliban has been
fighting for decades
we've been over there 19 years we're
like a
law enforcement force no administration
has been tougher on china than this
administration
while in office u.s president donald
trump has made many moves on the
international stage
he recognized jerusalem as the capital
of israel something virtually
no other world leader has done since
israel's founding
in 1948
he's also the first sitting president to
step foot in north korea
the donald trump presidency has found
best friends with a lot of rising
autocracies which is
an endemic challenge today in the world
there's
a real backsliding of political
liberalization
the trump administration has pulled
america out of a number of
key international agreements the paris
climate accord the trans-pacific
partnership
the iran nuclear deal and the open skies
treaty
one expert i spoke with who now lives in
london but is an american
says he thinks the world is looking at
the united states with a mix
of pity and disdain i think that if
donald trump is elected to another four
years in office
it will not only completely change the
fabric
of the american nation but um
and i think permanently but it will also
permanently we will permanently lose our
sort of preeminent standing in the world
and other countries
will begin to go our own way which is
what's been happening over the past four
years
economic leaders wield power america
and china are battling to be seen as the
world's leading economy
fractured political relationships
domestic chaos such as civil rights
abuses
and out-of-control deaths related to the
pandemic
are damaging america's image i think
if there is a biden presidency there
will be a lot of
repairing bilateral relationships the
future of the united states role in the
world is very much on the ballot
and the eyes of the world will be
watching
november 3rd crystal gomencing global
news
london martini
shaken not stirred how sean connery
managed to snag the role as
james bond
seven actors have taken on the role of
hollywood's most seductive spy
james bond but sean connery was the
first double 07
on the big screen he almost didn't get
the gig but the film franchise
launched the working-class scotsman to
start him
connery died today at the age of 90.
megan revell reports on the legacy
he leaves behind scottish movie legend
sean connery who shot to international
stardom playing james bond
has died aged 90. the actor graced the
silver screen for four decades
raised in near poverty in the slums of
edinburgh he worked as a coffin polisher
and milkman
before his bodybuilding hobby helped
launch an acting career
that made him one of the world's biggest
stars how important
was james bond in the development of
sean connery
well obviously very important because of
the
worldwide attention it drew to one and j
put one into another market and bracket
all together
as bond his debonair manor and rye humor
belied a darker
violent edge he is credited with
crafting a depth of character that set
the standard
for those who followed him in the role
such as british actor daniel craig for
me sean connery defined the role so he's
always going to be someone i'd look
you know i looked towards uh when i was
one especially when i started this and
you know dr known from russia would love
it two of my favorite films
connery played a series of noteworthy
roles besides double07
winning an academy award for his role in
the 1987 movie the untouchables
he was an ardent supporter of scotland's
independence
so much so that he had the words
scotland forever tattooed on his arm
when he was knighted by britain's queen
elizabeth in 2000
he wore full scottish dress including
the kilt of his mother's clan
connery retired from movies after
disputes with the director of his final
outing
the league of extraordinary gentlemen in
2003.
and that was megan ravel reporting on
the career of movie legend sean connery
who passed away today at his home in the
bahamas
still ahead why facts matter the
canadian take
on the american election
tonight on global our new season of the
new reality begins with donna friesen
it'll cover many issues that matter to
all of us donna is in washington for
global's coverage of the american
election and she's here now to tell us
what to expect for the new reality hi
donna
hi robin the new reality is back when we
started this program in the spring our
focus was on the pandemic
that is still a huge issue of course and
we'll keep covering it
but we've expanded to include other
issues that impact our new reality
including
u.s politics the whole world wants to
know if donald trump will get four more
years in the white house
and that's the focus of saturday's
program we'll introduce you to the fact
checker in chief of the american
commander-in-chief his name
is daniel dale you may have seen him on
cnn he's canadian
and he's not afraid to call a lie a lie
as we get closer to election dates
whether it is
this election or the 2018 midterms in
addition to the
ad-libbed impromptu lies that that he is
known for
there's start to be more lies written
into his speeches
what do you think is behind that i think
trump and his campaign
know that they can get inaccurate false
information
to millions of people unfiltered because
the outlets that these people are
consuming are not fact-checking him
we'll have lots more too including a
report on how canada is preparing for
all potential outcomes
including what might happen if president
trump loses
but refuses to accept the results robin
looking forward to it donna and you can
watch the new reality tonight on global
tv
starting at 7 pm in most markets and at
9 pm
in saskatchewan and alberta
a day for candy up next the late
comedian
is honored this halloween
well i'm still a million bucks shy of
being a millionaire
john candy would have turned 70 today to
mark the occasion toronto proclaimed
october 31st
john candy day he grew up in east york
and began his comedy career toronto's
second city
his rise to fame through sctv took him
to hollywood
there he starred in classics like splash
uncle buck
and planes trains and automobiles he was
the co-owner of the toronto argonauts
football team from 1991 to 1994.
john candy died of a heart attack at the
age of 43.
trick-or-treating has been canceled in
parts of canada where cases of covid19
are surging everywhere else it can be
hard to feel festive with strict rules
and warnings in place
but as mike drillet explains the virus
hasn't spooked
creative canadians
there's so much to be fearful of on
halloween ghouls monsters
so many princesses and this year it's
all going to unfold under an eerie blue
moon
but alas it's 20 20 and the scariest
monster
is the virus we can't see so what are
canadians doing
our latest polling suggests 49 are
turning off their porch lights
and doing nothing leaving kids to fend
for themselves
i'm going to buy boxes like 100 candies
and just sit in my room and eat them
depending on where he lives he could
forgo eating that box himself
and go door to door health officials
have given the green light for most of
the country
yet only 23 percent of canadians plan on
giving it a go
for those who try finding candy will be
difficult
because less than a third of atlantic
canada and those living in the middle of
the country say they'll be handing out
treats
and it's going to be even harder in bc
ontario and quebec
take a little bite fortunately not
everyone is scared off
to keep his haunted tunnel alive this
san lazar quebec man brought in security
to enforce distancing rules
and what kid won't want to visit former
global national reporter jen tryon's
house
zip line right to the roof right down to
the kids it's so fun
so there are safe trick-or-treat options
out there you just have to be creative
and embrace 2020 for what it is
a year when waiting for the school bus
dressed like spiderman
a dinosaur or a unicorn isn't that odd
after all
mike drollet global news toronto
and that is global national for this
saturday i'm robin gill
we'll stick with the halloween theme for
your candidate tonight
this pandemic-appropriate jack-o-lantern
in richmond bc weighs in at a whopping
794 pounds thank you for watching and
i'll see you back here tomorrow have a
great night
[Music]
you